sempre tipo quel po che mi hanno fatto
di pietro e te lo ricordi così chiamata
essere quello bravo quello però non
si farà bene niente
[Musica]
oggi nuovissime che pronunciano massimo
mare dalla giungla secondo
maggiore effettuano dei mostri delle
cose strane il senso che siamo stati
lasciati indietro dal nostro gruppo di
campeggiatori è stato un campeggiando
nella giungla abbiamo bisogno di
scappare ok dobbiamo baia poi entrare
dentro questa carretta meno male che si
merita ma non mi fa entrare dai sbrigati
quello abbiamo questo accesso pro non la
casetta sull'albero mali dove abbiamo
campeggiato no non c'è niente quello che
c'è
arrivati quasi quasi fa salta star di
questa è una di quelle skip room vecchio
stile quelle classiche sono sempre dei
temi affrontati voi
e come nel film bruno vecchietti vitale
si sfracella sono sott'acqua
grazie ok ok ci riprovo per un artista
racener abitare
ma dobbiamo saltare su questi pali
a proposito fatte già parte della nostra
esperti per entrare a far parte di tali
sistemi di furbata iscrivervi lascia è
un vi piace e sono lo avete ancora letto
leggere il mio libro
stallo avete capito di legge monselice
volevate volo sapere nei commenti siete
tutta forme spingano così tempo i sui
tag che dovete
ricordando i borsoni in google transit e
forse li celebriamo solo stare attenti
no dice che spingano girarono cioè
girano no non penso ma non si muovono
infatti forse voler dire fanno affatto
ma non tirare la testa quelli ti
confondono il cadi come ho fatto io
adesso
chi arriverà per primo che prenderà il
peggior finale per primo l'italia quando
questo stato veloce vitale juan che
commette chi arriverà per primo e
vediamo se poi alla fine del video
avrete vinto la scommessa più figo ci
sono tipo inizioni di poco
scendiamo al noto in italia ma è un
giallo giusto lo stesso ma sai che non
lo so credo di sì o fa vitelli ha
superato accordando velocissimo
milano nord ha fatto solo minuto
no non mi hai superato sono ancora qui
guardando solo davanti dei no sono io
davanti a studenti come già detto il
vice questi blocchi sembrano un po
strani frutti voci sopra va bene vizio
che sembrano strani salta visto giusto
che comincia per bella cascata morto
adesso dobbiamo salire sugli alberi che
bella però questo script lug sugli
alberi
sempre di fare una vacanza e aspetta un
momento dove bisognerà alzare adesso a
destra sfinito stai giocando solo
dobbiamo andare qua
no no ferito il contagio per altri
bayard ed apprezzare un incontro di
riguarda la strada volendo strada però
trovato l'ho trovata eccovi tare laggiù
cadrà oro carrai ma che cosa sono questi
fra sette erano dei cugini della nostra
serie a il suo vigilanza ruggeri ei
tronchi o niente che sono decisione ha
ragioni tira giustizia che ben
noti si straccerà tutto questo non stavo
guardando lo vedete stato e mafia
solo che tutto sulla prima margherita è
una marina le erano marcati sono
margherita queste però dai colori un po
strani non credo che se la margherita e
non diventano così grande cassino ci si
può arrampicare sopra prendi il vaso di
fiori e devi innaffiare le piante così
possiamo salire sopra
crescere le piante è
venuto appreso guarda countdown bagni a
parlare dove d'avanguardia
spero che mi che sul fatto che sta
scritto un nuovo ad annaffiare le labbra
piazza che fanno accaduto al povero si è
un annaffiatoio magico
sovrana tc la soglia dei sistemi sì che
figo ok ok da pont dai sfracellate in
obbligati prematuri
sono già accaduto troppe volte questa
volta stava attento
sul passaggio sarebbe stato buono ti ho
mangiato qualcuno siamo dentro una
grotta pavimento alla va p quindi vuol
dire che vi sarebbe
mamma perché è riuscita a passare questa
parte quel super equilibrio che ho fatto
tutto anzi sono già tipo 34 stage più
avanti
piano da schiappa deve prendere il
peggio prima di me
[Musica]
why
salvatico si salva stecche strada ma
faccio saltare questo amore che caso
mio nonno era assolutamente non solo
caduta giù mai mai mai mai bas peccato
non ti sei strage la tav è neanche una
volta certo che hanno schiacciato il
link dello stesso indice del signore
questo signore basta premi quel bottone
la e passa attraverso la lava però
attendono far cadere il tempo ok
[Musica]
lo so ma lo troverò prima limitare o 600
davanti
ho trovato il motore pò troppo
bagnata strada ma dove l'hai trovato
questo bottone che la capiente
no non l'avevo visto prima
l'ultima ma
non meno che
presto ve lo chiedono
ora può bisogna saltare su questo ponte
che un corrotto ti avviso non è facile
perché vita e l'orchestra celle atac ora
purtroppo porta volta che di capitale
sfracellato
possibile lo è il karma il karma stai
calma di serie a ma stai ancora lì su
quel ponte di
jaffa comunicato perché un tale troppo
bravo e tu nella scappa e viene partite
nelle prime steve rumbo vitale quanto
raschiato campagna mentite cose si sono
migliorato se non ci credete andate a
vedere le nostre vecchie sky promuove e
quante volte ci sfracellata dai che ce
la puoi fare ti vedo non ce l'hai fatta
finalmente ok vediamo cosa di gioia ha
detto non dice niente di
vero nord aspetta adesso dice sembra che
questo muro sia bloccato forse c'è un
modo di aprirlo ti siamo state l'azzurro
non ci credo hai trovato prima su di
festa premiamo il pulsante eight è
aperto al muro
sono tornato
e tutto adesso di supero c'è ma io con
una scimmia gigante qualcosa mi dice che
ora arriverà poi parlando aspetta
aspetta aspetta ma prima di entrare nel
tempio ma vuol dire come sono mangiati
dalla scimmia può essere
[Musica]
pensiamo per vedere che succede
aspetta aspetta aspetta aletti che poi
dopo c'è una scimmia gigante che ci
mangia e poi noi dobbiamo uscire dopo
l'arresto
del te che mi sono fermato ma perché
allora vedo che c'è qualcosa lì
c'è un tempio sputo un tempio è sembrato
strano che cos'è un tempio forma di
trani
bene così posso superare il vestito
avantissimo che se non voglio essere la
prima entrare nella bolletta
è sì un drago sputafuoco vedi bene ma tu
sei troppo capito alcune
catene speriamo che il drago non sia mai
che non ci lascia passare da quella base
brutta e marrone bene iniziate a questa
mostra che maggior parte va beh io ci
devo tornare alla di su 32 sta
succedendo questa cosa strategies fra
celiamo nello stesso identico punto
secondo pensi tu che mi fai aspetta
guarda che stai sbagliando strada
non ci sono
altre banale abbiamo è che questa può
sembrare una sorta di scimmia non
bisogna
[Musica]
bisogno di adottarle certo non è giusto
essere una scimmia non entrato ricevuta
fuoco
forte preferiscono gialli potuto marrone
qui
[Musica]
ho passato luci che tutto ti sei sposata
in suo passato ma dovrà consegnare una
possibile assolutamente sta davvero
diventando super bravo
signora
guardando freddo
ci sono questi toni roboanti pericolosi
che ci sono intoppi dobbiamo cercare di
evitarle wow sembra tipo indiana jones
ma ho capito che una super estivo
[Musica]
è arrivato una mina vagante
arrotolato via allora bisogna stare
superate le mine vaganti sono
velocissime
a mano no aspetta dove sei andato
perso perché non sai
tutto difficile non è così difficile
come sembra dai vado prima io ne
sta invitare sulla caccia la posso fare
anch'io
e stata una passeggiata e sono anche il
vantaggio
[Musica]
da janine ti aspetto
avanti
[Musica]
basta
mai
abbiamo salutato con questa il tempio su
queste rocce un po strani a sembrano
tipo sempre tipo quel po che hanno fatto
di pietra te lo ricordi come si
chiamava no mi vedevo quello però non è
male ma non è detto che ti ricordi dei
poveri
a proposito avete visto il video
indovina il login tre secondi rimuovete
vederlo perché in quel video c'è vitale
che provengono i vagoni dei pokémon ed è
riuscito a chiamare i ghisa ur torta il
libro
non avete visto andate a vederlo dopo
perché fa troppo ridere questo è invece
sembra stato senza isterismi acicatena
prima volta sì ma ci sono questi
spuntoni tigre del no mi hanno appena
appena appunto tra pil mentre spunta
bellissimo strumento per la troppo bello
stacco di trappole via ok allora quando
dico via passiamo che no
tanto atteso che sfocia ligure tu lo so
secondo me ci sono dei selezioni a
pressione che praticamente loro
capiscono quando noi stiamo passando e
quindi e quindi che quindi si attivano
iniziati volano quando sentono la
pressione e cielo di fitto si riguardo
vedi basta andare indietro poco poco e
si aprono e vito
[Musica]
ok l'ultimo luogo l'ultima teniamoci
all'ultimo
team periodo di questo albero sembra
molto figo
problemi vediamo dall'africa i rami ok
ma terme rigiocando lo capisco come
facciamo da grafica ci sono pro v che
fino adesso queste skype room perché
facciamo cose che non potremmo mai fare
nella vita reale arrampicata cina altri
giganti saltare sulla lava
non capisco come come prima ne sono
sull'albero ti capito lo so perché mi
sono nascosto bene
[Musica]
a molto evitare fate le cose e finché
non capisco veramente quello che è il
motivo cioè se quello che si è
arrampicato l'altro è diventato sarah
l'ha detto lui perché ha detto
arrampicati sugli alberi loro
viaggio 0 avanti non dovevo andare
avverrà nuovo diamo cielo aspettando di
ficcare che si scatenerà dico faranno
giusto in caso di pericolo che pasolini
ecco la lazio
[Musica]
ne ha fato mi piace per portare fortuna
a vitale vediamo allora come devo fare a
passare qui a casa devo andare sopra da
qui e poi c'è la statua wow
sempre nel vostro mi piace ha funzionato
ha portato fortuna vitale perché youtube
ai nerazzurri
trattato e allora in frigo questa
mattonella sospese come fanno a
mantenersi in aria credo che siano
pietre ma scorrendo le moto nel popolo
sorelle non è tutto
dove andiamo
[Applauso]
piacevoli
credo per un ambiente mai preso tu non è
giusto c'era così povero cosimino
prendono gli ho detto se l'abbiamo fatta
ora puoi trovare riesce a trovare il
belgio segreto il prezzo segreto due
salve vediamo troveremo il badge
sentiamo troppo
usiamo lo speed pad così siamo
velocissimi e già pad per saltare in
altissimo io potete chiamarlo io non ho
mai trovato nessun badge segreto qui si
è mai riusciti nelle ski promo trovare
del segreto
dove sei
una di questi peruviana ghiaccio no io
so quello di fuoco invece
riesco a vedere liete vediamo dai semi
mai riuscita a vedere qualcosa da qua
sopra mi stavo sfracellando lecce
segreto dove
opera proveniente
[Musica]
come vorrebbe
ci credono riuscito a trovare pure il
penoso creato
ma presto non la prendo sì eccolo l'è
preso
[Applauso]
stravinto bravissima la vita che hai
trovato dai preso quel primo invece hai
trovato anche quando segreto di corbara
minacciate da cliccare per vedere i
nostri altri video le case su quella
preferita buona vittima ciao